if you're new to movement training and
animal flow
then you probably have one enduring
impression of the training modality
people crawling around the ground
crawling exercises
certainly pose a striking image seeing
someone crawl like a lizard through the
bushes
is definitely a little unusual whether
it's edo portal
animal flow gmb or father fitness
crawling is a common feature among many
different approaches
to movement training but is it just a
gimmick or are there real tangible
benefits to the bear crawl and lizard
crawl
well the short answer is yes there are
many benefits to the back rule and other
locomotive exercises like it
there are even more when we get a little
inventive with the different variations
we can do
the first benefit of crawling then is
that it develops strength endurance
especially throughout the core
when you crawl you are under continuous
tension this means that the muscles
involved get no time to rest and are
flooded with blood and metabolites that
stimulate growth
this actually makes crawling a good move
for hypertrophy this is especially true
for the lizard crawl exercise
as you keep your body low to the ground
and therefore maintain an isometric
contraction
in the pecs triceps and shoulders more
to the point this type of training will
develop
strength endurance that allows you to
exert strength for a long time
without getting exhausted something that
is crucial whether doing manual labor
or competing in a sport especially mma
many people get immediately put off by
the bear crawl after trying it for a few
minutes concluding that it isn't tough
enough
but try crawling for one mile and now
tell me how your entire body is feeling
treat this like loaded carry
alternatively try using crawling in the
place of running
battle ropes or kettlebells in a bout of
high-intensity interval training
and if that's still not challenging
enough crawl faster
i someday hope to see a world where it's
not unusual to see someone crawling down
the road or
carrying a kettlebell down the road why
should we be restricted to public
exercises
that other people deem to be normal
people be like
why are you doing something that i don't
immediately understand
and i'm like what but more so than the
arms and legs the bare coral lizard
crawl exercises
also keep the core under constant
tension this makes the movement work
very much like a plank or any other
isometric hold for the torso
the problem with the plank is that it's
boring and not terribly challenging once
you develop a certain amount of fitness
the bear crawl or lizard crawl allow you
to get the benefits of the plank while
also getting plenty of
other advantages like the aforementioned
strength insurance for the upper body
the lizard crawl in particular has the
added benefit of also training the
obliques
in an anti-rotation capacity this has
fantastic transfer for any movement that
involves a resisting rotation
such as wrestling this is also where the
crab crawl or tabletop exercise comes in
useful
this movement has you upside down groin
side up crawling like a crab
this works the endurance of the hip
extensors and director spinae in a
similar manner
which often get overlooked and are
actually more important for many people
strength endurance in the core can make
you more athletic across the board
and potentially prevent injury another
benefit is that many crawls also enhance
mobility
in the lizard crawl you'll be reaching
over your head while at the same time
bringing your knee up by your side
you can also exaggerate this movement
further if you prefer
this is good because it means you're
moving in the frontal plane and it means
you're exploring a wider range of motion
this is particularly beneficial if you
want to improve hip mobility
another great exercise for mobility is
what gmb calls the bear
this is a little confusing as a bear
crawl is often associated with the foot
hand crawl
that's called the bear call exercise in
parkour but beast in animal flow
so we can call these movements whatever
we like really there's no right or wrong
way
and that really is the fun of movement
training either way the gmb
bear or downward dog walk is like the
bear exercise where your butt is
sticking in the air
this is fantastic for improving your
pancake stretch and opening up the
shoulders
why spend ages in a static stretch
position when you can be training your
endurance while getting passive mobility
gains as well
this is once again that concept of bang
for your buck exercises
then there's the fact that the bear
crawl is a cross body movement making it
excellent for coordination
and proprioception crawling is a
movement we perform in infancy
and this helps us to develop the crucial
connection between the right shoulder
and left hip and vice versa we see this
connection in the serape effect
whenever we walk or go to throw a ball
this may also be partly responsible for
the unusual wiring that connects the
left side of the body
to the right side of the brain and vice
versa the nerves that travel from the
brain to the peripheral nervous system
cross at the medulla
in the brain stem this is known as the
lateral corticospinal tract
so now you know in short contralateral
movements that cross the midline
have potential to thicken the important
bundle of nerves that connect
the left and right hemispheres the
corpus callosum a movement like the
push-up for example
requires less processing power than a
crawl because both arms are moving
through the exact same range of motion
there is one set of instructions split
across two limbs
but moving your limbs independently
requires you to divide
your attention and effectively
multi-thread your cerebrum
finally crawls also incorporate a
balancing aspect
the exercise known as bird dog involves
resting on all fours and reaching
forwards and back with contralateral
limbs
this is often used as a warm-up or
mobility exercise and is fantastic for
stabilizing the core
while balancing on two points to do this
we must be aware of the multifidus which
is a long string of small muscles
running up either side of the spine
these muscles are extremely strong and
contribute heavily to spinal stiffness
but they are also rich in muscle
spindles making them highly sensitive
that's because the multifidus must
listen to and anticipate movements
and embrace the body to stabilize
against them
the bear crawl or lizard crawl
effectively utilize the same challenge
this is effectively a moving bird dog
and therefore allow you to improve your
balance and coordination even further
this also makes this an excellent way to
warm up and prime the nervous system
before a workout all crawling movements
also benefit from being highly compound
that means they utilize many muscle
groups and joints working together
thereby improving general coordination
and athletic application of strength
you're not just building the muscles but
the connections between those muscles
and possibly the epi-muscular force
transmission that may occur via the
fascia
it should come as no surprise then to
learn that studies have found
quadrupedal movement
to improve both proprioception and
markers of cognition
this type of training was shown to
improve performance on the wisconsin
card sorting task who'd have thought
that crawling around the ground
could make you better at sorting cards
[Music]
hopefully i've convinced you that the
bear crawl and lizard crawl are
valuable as they are but once you start
getting creative they can become
even more interesting you can
incorporate any exercise you like with
the bear crawl or lizard crawl
just as you can incorporate movements
with the push-up for example you could
include a kick-through after every two
steps
or you could combine the movement with a
burpee this turns the movement into a
kind of complex or hybrid exercise
in parkour the bear crawl is often used
for balancing along beams
railings or branches this drastically
increases the role of equilibrioception
and proprioception
the core lights up and you'll even feel
your grip working over time if you're on
a railing
in short it might sound or look easy but
it's an amazingly full body workout
and better yet this may even have more
benefits for the brain
now you really have to listen to that
multifidus and create tiny changes
in the amount of tension in each limb to
prevent yourself from toppling off
i've discussed at length how cognitively
challenging any kind of movement is
and how much information must be
processed at any time this may be why
studies show training that incorporate
balancing asynchronous limb movement and
manipulation
may actually improve focus visual
spatial processing and more
this actually increases the gray matter
of the basal ganglia and you can check
the full written version of this post
over at the bioneer.com if you want to
see the studies that back this up
best of all research from tracy and ross
alloway suggest the climbing trees
crawling along beams and running
barefoot can all help to increase
working memory
if you want to know why this might be
the case then i highly recommend
watching my last video
where i talk about how visual processing
actually involves
working memory to a very large degree
and the same goes for other types of
sensory information
another cruel variation you can do is to
move laterally from side to side or
backwards
and moving side to side is particularly
useful because there are so few
exercises
that move you in that frontal plane want
to turn this into a more brutal
conditioning workout
then try tugging an object while
crawling get a harness that's 15
for amazon then attach some resistance
bands to a few weight plates or a
sandbag
this is one of the only bodyweight
exercises that can train pulling muscles
without suspending a bar or a ring it's
also a great way to increase the
resistance
and it's a fantastic workout for your
mental fortitude you'll even feel your
fingers and grip working to try and dig
into the floor if you do this on grass
it takes the crawl from something that
might look like a bit of a gimmick into
a really punishing workout
where you'll really feel that pressure
though is in the quads because that
angle means that you're really pushing
off the legs against the most resistance
another way to instantly make the bear
crawl exercise
or any other crawling movement more
challenging is to crawl up or down hill
going up is a great alternative to rock
climbing if you don't have a center or
crag near you
coming back down meanwhile places much
more pressure on the shoulders
especially the anterior deltoids this
can be easily incorporated into a trail
run
for awesome full body benefits throw on
some minimal shoes go for a run across
some rough terrain
do some pull-ups from a tree branch
crawl along it then crawl down a hill
you'll light up those supporting muscles
your grip and your cerebrum
in ways that you can't manage by simply
repeating curls and squats in a cushy
gym
to conclude then crawling exercises
certainly have a lot to offer
and can complement nearly any training
program but you have to treat it like a
serious part of your routine
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please consider leaving a like and
sharing it around that helps me out
immensely and i appreciate it so much
just clicking subscribe or commenting
down below really helps the channel to
grow
if you want to learn more about
functional training then be sure to
check out my new book
functional training and beyond available
now from all good bookstores
that's an in-depth discussion around
functional training and the place that
it should have in all of our lives
alternatively you could try my ebook and
training program super functional
training
the super functional program is designed
to increase performance across the board
from cognitive function to speed to
strength and there's a discount on right
now
while we're all dealing with the
pandemic subscribe of course if you'd
like to see more like this
and thanks a ton for watching this one
see you next time
and bye for now
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]